beautiful she truly looks exactly like  Cindy Cindy Crawford and her look-alike  daughter Kaia Gerber are back at it  again  totally twinning and we totally love it  the 50 year old model posted this pic to  Instagram on Tuesday their pose the same  their hair color same matching black  jumpsuits same the gorgeous gals have a  seriously doing a double-take no smoke  and mirrors I think but it's hardly the  first look-alike moment we've seen from  the pair earlier this year they graced  the cover of Vogue Paris and if you need  more proof here's Cindy morphing into  kaya in a chrome heart sad  here they are hiking here they are with  Taylor Swift  and here they are twinning with two dogs  who are also 20 that I think gives me a  lot of confidence there's no doubt Cindy  and kaya art winning and winning